other parties trade in fear
we start with hope is it any wonder the
trust in politics has broken down to the
extent that it has let's have a trade
deal with Europe but make our own laws
no one standing here is going to win
this election
outright I'm not even gonna pretend that
I haven't made a mistake put my hands up
when I have and I've learned from this
election is a chance to change the
Westminster system so we will make
Scotland's voice here'd the choice that
this election is sticking with a plan
that's working or going back to the debt
taxes borrowing and spending that got us
in this mess in the first place plaid
Camry offers an alternative we offer
hope I say Britain could do so much
better than it's done over the last five
years I think it's all about balance
isn't it cut less than the Conservatives
and we'll borrow less than Labour we
could save another ten billion pounds a
year by not paying over money to
Brussels every single day if you don't
understand the mistakes of the past you
can't provide the leadership for the
future English taxpayers are a bit
cheesed off with so much of their money
going over Hadrian's Wall more debt and
more taxes more debt and more taxes a
lot more debt and more taxes of course
we all love the NHS but the NHS doesn't
need warm words it needs hard cash a
Camry is proud that we give the world's
the NHS and we've had a really dangerous
damaging debate about immigration there
are 7,000 diagnosis in this country
every year for people who are HIV
positive but 60% of them are not British
nationals anything that Nigel Farage
wouldn't believe on foreigners the NHS
is creaking at the seams imagine what it
would be like with another five years of
David Cameron I don't think it's
prejudice to worry about immigration my
Camry won't go along with the
scapegoating of migrants I think the
views of the West Minister parties on
this issue have been driven by the fear
of UK I told you at the start they were
all the same but they all agreed and
they do so the Green Party does support
a referendum on Europe we would they
would not even be a
about a referendum if it wasn't for the
rise of UK seems to think that every
single problem in the world could be
solved by a referendum on Europe we need
a school system that isn't focused on
exam none of these guys can be trusted
when it comes to tuition fees hope
there's some SNP MPs in the House of
Commons keeping home or none of us can
afford more austerity the SNP offers an
alternative make sure that we don't
lurch this way or that if I'm Prime
Minister I'll make sure we reward the
hard work of everybody in our country
for weir's to be strong like Scotland
plight Kamri must be strong you don't
have to go on voting for the lesser of
two evils see I warned you at the
beginning I said they were all the same
they don't understand the thoughts hopes
and aspirations of ordinary people in
this country so I want us to finish the
job that we've all started stick with
the plan and with a team who brought
that plan because it's working and it's
helping